hello there reject nation I'm G Alba
this is s Lomonaco you look stupid you
look dumb guys false Ali are you a brush
we'll never return
friendship is not me anything in LA
Sally do you like Family Guy
you've heard of Family Guy right what
I'm kidding Jesus not like [ __ ]
casting directors are watching this some
of the truth you know
let's try not to laugh challenge Family
Guy challenge number 10
Sally do not laugh okay try your best
not to smile okay that was pretty good
but actually when you said me llamo East
Brian you don't need the ACE just mammal
Brian oh you speak English no just that
first Beach and this one explaining it
you you're kidding right okay
[Music]
okay Jack nobody get married and
everything you promised
yeah about that I was pretty sure I was
gonna die because actually this is Carol
in New York and it's getting kind of
serious but you know thank you let me
draw you naked
I still can't believe you let me do that
can we get some salami and Brian let me
handle this
that's 2z having a poopy cake all huh
Peter what are you doing speaking
Italian you can't speak Italian just
because you have a moustache now this is
just a suggestion just throw it out
there
have you considered abortion Peter I
think it's too late for that
oh don't let the press put this charity
a wave Lee Boggs has not been overturned
yeah but you can't really aboard a live
baby oh boy ahem got you
madam
[Music]
four years later me and Lois divorced
until we die yes
oh you know I think you should all be
master to quit readin the way I treat my
colleague what what I think you mean a
certain you say wheat wheat now say will
we will we will we will we will we
hooked up Whoopi Goldberg on the show
all the time Lois Lois used to be
married so for my mom knew it no mom no
mommy mommy mommy no no no ah mah mah
mah mah mum mum mum mum mummy mummy ma
ma ma ma ma ma Hey thank goodness Pete
about a huge supply of dehydrated meals
before the blast
Peter what are you doing you just ate a
year's worth of food everyone leave I
have to pull now oh it's like when I get
blue what do you want just lying there
taking it if it was me I would have done
too controversial
we notice large quantities of benzene
ephedrine and everyday Epsom salt have
gone missing please we both know those
are the ingredients used to make crystal
meth and I've got a pretty good idea who
you've been selling it to as well okay
beaker when you're done talking your
friend I wanna talk about that
okay good sauerkraut that is good
the outer bond from drones is good oopah
music that is good euthanasia for the
mentally feeble - is good is film before
audience of the mentally fever
oh Jesus I wish I could get tickets for
that show before I start playing I'm
gonna eat this whole sandwich
[Applause]
well looks like someone's in the zone so
I see you graduated number one in your
class from Princeton that's right and
I'm certified as an accountant and also
have a law degree
that's all very impressive we'll keep
you in mind let's see pointy boobs
medium pointy boobs not so pointy boobs
that's a shame not this time I mean look
at that dog over there you think he
wants to be tied to that chair waiting
in the hot Sun while his owner gets ice
cream hell no I'm gonna make people see
that an animal's life is just as
important as a human's fellow canine be
free and enjoy life
[Music]
maybe that's why he was tied up happy
birthday sweet head Lionel Richie's
can't slow down
great album Louis great album I didn't
know who I was until I heard you shout
like those years when it was just Miley
and me hey my dogs chewing up that thing
I need hey my dirty dogs jumping in the
neighbor's pool wait Marley don't shake
your wet fur in the middle of this fancy
party
I'm gonna lay down these work blueprints
on the floor and I sure hope you don't
walk across him with money boys my
nightmare dog is dead Marley & Me
[Music]
took that black chick home hey hey
you're welcome
how was it over you feel okay yeah I
yeah what's wrong what that was easy for
me come on Seth MacFarlane it's kind of
weirdly edited this time around yeah
they cut like things that mean the
Italian things almost got me early on
boopity boopity boopity boopity bit of
ooh I love that bit I've seen that big
countless time there's certain bits here
that for the abortion thing I've
recommended that for so many people
who've just had a baby you know I guess
some people just I might consider it you
know like having a baby stuff and every
once in a while you think you want a kid
welcome to day two you can't sleep baby
won't shut up you didn't read the book
there's got to be some like post
abortion you really good baby right now
why did you have a dead baby look if
there's two things I've learned about an
improv comedy class you don't joke about
two things aids aids an abortion is what
I was taught we taught that no I was
taught you were taught no limits man
everything should be made but might as
well kill babies you just lost a family
I did oh but that mom bit the mum mummy
that gets me every time it's like that's
me to my mom every day just to annoy her
I don't know how to download ringtones
anymore when ever since I got an iPhone
but years ago when I had like a Nokia I
was able to download that and have it be
my ringtone for my mom and I'll tell you
got on my nerves I realized she calls me
to office sick of this family guy yeah I
loved how they made Jesus Christ a
character in the show a dude who takes
advantage of his powers which makes me
go I wish Jesus Christ could be a
superhero comic book
they have that it's called the Bible man
the Bible man
that's not the Jesus though yeah I know
you're right I've read that you know
that though I thought you wouldn't know
it I know I read the action Bible I
believe you know be cool I think King
Jesus in the MCU would be great yeah I
mean he could totally defeat Thanos you
didn't even do anything
no it's just like man upstairs you're
gon love me some Jesus powers man Oh
when Peter is going down Lois that was
funny she opens her eyes I should just
end it after that like I'd say that
doesn't work though I know that doesn't
work have you tried it have you tried it
obviously doesn't work I mean obviously
you wouldn't know try an x-ray of my
body is no way that works are you sure
yes yeah cuz I've tried it doesn't work
it doesn't work I mean she blew it into
me and did nothing about my mouth it
kind of just a flex back I don't even
know how to get it inside yeah
should you make another dead baby Jeff
oh but we can relate with the won't
worst if he walks in on Meg oh yeah I
mean whoo that's happening with us
ugly tits is that what you mean are you
saying I have ugly tits I remember when
you walked in on me and but you just
walked out I'm very comfortable around
freezing cold pool these are some really
old call backs been watching our videos
for a very long time
no or referencing right now to you that
clip now I have to do editing and fire I
wouldn't say you have not so pointy
boobs they're liking this video so I
have over the category pointy boobs
medium pointy boobs not so pointy boobs
would you say you have naturally I'd say
I have
boobs but like bras make you look like
less of pointy
that's why bras ruin things see but if
it were the 60s would be different
because they had the bras in the sixties
were like pointing so I was like popular
exactly and then somewhere long lines
they're lying
no times have really gotten worse since
the sixties now like you're just
grandma's have those bras figured this
is the best post try not to laugh
challenge conversation subscribe to the
react nation click that notification
Bell isn't she adorable go follow her on
YouTube